Today, we’re gonna be taking a look at one
of the odder SCPs in the Foundation’s custody.
The Foundation has plenty of weird and downright
silly anomalies, as we’ve covered extensively
in the past.
Plenty of them are objects that you wouldn’t
imagine need to be under heavy containment,
but you’d be wrong.
Even innocuous household objects with a harmless,
albeit annoying anomaly can pose an immense
danger to normalcy and human life.
So today we’re gonna be taking a look at
SCP-2966, affectionately and nervously referred
to by scientists on break and at the water
cooler with an odd nickname: the Infinite
TP.
TP, of course, refers to exactly what you’re
thinking: toilet paper.
Just based off that nickname, you’ve probably
already gotten a pretty good idea of what
this anomaly is, but you’d be surprised.
Just because something is predictable doesn’t
mean its harmless, or easy to contain.
SCP-2966 is contained at Outpost 117, a small,
isolated little facility far, far out in the
icy tundras of northern Canada, well away
from any other settlements or Foundation sites.
It’s kept so far away because any other
SCP objects coming into contact with SCP-2966
is incredibly dangerous, and prohibited under
any circumstances.
It’s also kept so far away from cities or
towns for another reason - below the ground,
Outpost 117 is host to an experimental thorium
nuclear reactor.
Thorium reactors are highly efficient nuclear
reactors, but only a few exist in the entire
world for scientists to perform research upon.
What’s one doing under a tiny, out of the
way facility in the Canadian wilderness?
Well, all nuclear reactors produce a lot of
heat and energy, as they’re designed to.
This reactor is right next to the containment
chamber SCP-2966 is locked in, pumping heat
into the chamber at incredibly high temperatures.
SCP-2966 can only be removed for experimentation,
study, or cleaning when enough heat has been
pumped into the chamber to heavily reduce
how much matter there is.
But the SCP Foundation is in the business
of containing anomalies, not destroying them
like the GOC.
Why would they be using nuclear power to slowly
and constantly degrade what seems like a fairly
innocuous anomaly?
Well, clearly it’s not entirely innocuous.
Outpost 117’s staff is as barebones as the
facility itself: only a single skeleton crew
of 16 people, just enough to keep the facility
and its reactor up and running without risking
any casualties.
Three nuclear engineers trained in the upkeep
of nuclear reactors, and four Foundation researchers
to monitor the reactor and SCP-2966’s containment
chamber.
Along with that, there are 8 trained soldiers
from the Foundation’s MTFs to guard the
facility and its perimeter 25km out from the
outpost itself.
But that’s only 15 people - who’s the
16th?
Well, unsurprisingly, it’s a D-class subject,
to be used for direct experimentation with
the anomaly.
Considering most SCP sites have personnel
counts in the hundreds of even thousands,
16 seems remarkably little.
But the Foundation has learned their lesson
from past breach events involving SCP-2966.
The D-class in the orange jumpsuit has an
extremely important job, though.
Every eight hours, three times a day, the
D-class is to ‘use’ SCP-2966.
Given what we know the anomaly is… you can
imagine what that entails.
But whenever it is used, at least ten sheets
of toilet paper have to be removed from it
and, well, used.
That use is heavily monitored by the research
team and a few of the MTF troopers, and radio
communication is maintained throughout the
whole gross event.
The research team advises the D-class on whether
to speed up or slow down the rate at which
they tear off paper from SCP-2966.
There’s other equipment, too: a vast array
of sensors and scales to measure SCP-2966’s
mass and density, and the data is fed back
to the researchers and into the nuclear reactor’s
systems.
Needless to say, all of this is extremely
strange.
What could a roll of TP, infinite as it may
be, possibly do to warrant a dedicated research
team and nuclear reactor?
Not to mention regular use experiments and
constant monitoring of its data points?
Whatever it is, it’s dangerous.
The Foundation is currently constructing a
runway for jet aircraft just outside of Outpost
117, so that personnel can evacuate should
something go critical - not the nuclear reactor,
but SCP-2966.
Clearly, whatever it can do, it’s more worrisome
than a nuclear reactor going into meltdown.
We’ve got a lot of questions by now, so
let’s see if we can figure out what exactly
SCP-2966 does.
Our predictions from the name, however, were
entirely accurate: SCP-2966 is an anomalous
branded roll of toilet paper.
For security reasons, we can’t tell you
the brand, but we can tell you that it’s
entirely possible SCP-2966 might have a distant
cousin in your own bathroom.
The first strange thing about SCP-2966 is
its weight.
It weighs at least several kilograms, though
its weight is usually changing and Foundation
personnel are told not to try reducing it,
not after the incident.
Anyway, it sticks around 5 and a half kilograms.
You’ll notice that’s a lot heavier than
you’d expect a toilet paper roll to be,
given it’s made of… well, paper.
Its weight isn’t the only unusual thing
about it: it’s also really good toilet paper.
Anomalously good, even.
We won’t go into detail because I don’t
think anyone wants the details on that, but
let’s just say - the best toilet paper you’ve
ever used?
SCP-2966 is softer, stronger, better in every
way.
But once a sheet is ripped out of SCP-2966’s
roll, it’s not anomalous anymore, and can
be used and thrown away normally.
SCP-2966 itself is attached to the wall inside
a metal housing, the kind you’d see in a
public bathroom, with no way to remove or
replace it - not that it needs to be replaced.
X-rays and ultrasounds of the metal housing
are inconclusive, but the Foundation doesn't
want to cut into it with saws because… well,
you’ll see.
Not to mention the fact that the metal housing
is the main way the reactor’s heat is funneled
into SCP-2966, and playing with nuclear power
is a little risky.
But what’s actually anomalous about SCP-2966?
Well, it’s an infinite roll of toilet paper.
But we knew that already.
Since SCP-2966 was contained, at least 10
kilometres of toilet paper have been pulled
from it – over 6 miles!
The research team hasn’t seen any evidence
of it absorbing mass or producing new toilet
paper, and testing has revealed it’s not
pulling the paper from an alternate dimension
or reality.
Despite all the testing, the researchers are
baffled by how exactly SCP-2966 keeps producing
the toilet paper that it does.
But even if they don’t understand how it
happens, they have gained a pretty good understanding
of what the results are.
And the results are a lot less fun than you
might think.
See, SCP-2966 still obeys the first law of
thermodynamics: matter and energy can’t
be created or destroyed, only change forms.
So SCP-2966 doesn’t actually create toilet
paper so much as it absorbs energy from its
surroundings, then transforms that energy
into matter - more specifically, toilet paper.
How exactly it absorbs energy is unclear to
the Foundation, but they’ve run the math.
One sheet of SCP-2966 weighs approximately
three grams, which means that approximately
2.04×1016 joules of energy, or roughly 65
tons of TNT, is needed for one sheet of SCP-2966
to be produced.
From there, they were able to extrapolate
that SCP-2966 contains at least several thousand
sheets within the roll - an extremely, extremely
large amount of explosive power, all contained
in a roll of toilet paper.
Now you get why SCP-2966 is so dangerous.
It’s not just a roll of toilet paper - in
the wrong hands, it could be one of the most
powerful explosives ever detonated, easily
able to wipe out half a country.
But if you think that’s where SCP-2966’s
danger really lies, think again.
Removing SCP-2966’s sheets is harmless,
until you remove ten of them at a time.
Then it’ll start absorbing the energy around
it, at roughly the rate that sheets are removed.
It’s trying to rapidly gain energy to rebuild
itself, and it’ll get the energy from anything.
It’s usually in the form of heat energy,
but it’ll absorb anything, even sound!
But when there’s no active source of power,
SCP-2966 becomes dangerous.
It starts sucking up energy from the ambient
heat around it, and given the large amount
of energy, it sucks it up fast.
In only a few minutes, it can bring the temperature
of the room its in to absolute zero, completely
stopping all molecular activity.
This has happened twice when the power went
out at Outpost 117: both times, the casualties
were high.
Research personnel sacrificed themselves to
run into SCP-2966’s chamber and start ripping
sheets away from it, bringing the temperature
down.
They all died from hypothermia, but they saved
the entire site and stopped SCP-2966 from
going ‘critical’.
You see, when SCP-2966 isn’t used for a
while, it starts to decay.
The matter its gained in the form of toilet
paper is reduced back into pure energy: radiation.
Thankfully, it’s not ionizing radiation,
the kind you’d find in a nuclear bomb.
It’s simple heat and alpha radiation, mostly
harmless if you’re equipped right.
After extensive testing and more than a little
trial and error, the researchers figured out
the perfect distance between using SCP-2966
after letting it absorb energy, and letting
it decay into radiation: 8 hours.
That’s why the D-class has to use SCP-2966
every 8 hours, because if it goes over, something
very bad happens.
SCP-2966 decays matter and energy exponentially,
and gets faster and faster the longer its
left untouched.
Within a day and a half, SCP-2966 goes ‘critical’,
at which point the rate of energy radiation
gets so high that it starts rapidly getting
close to infinity.
Sounds like a lot of complicated physics,
right?
So let’s bring it down to terms all of us
will understand.
When the rate of energy decay becomes infinite,
what happens is that SCP-2966’s entire mass
is converted into energy in a single moment.
All that energy stockpile is released in one
gigantic, titanic explosion.
Remember how we mentioned that SCP-2966 could
feasibly be used as a bomb?
Yeah, this is that bomb exploding.
The explosion would result in at least 1000
megatons of TNT.
For comparison, the Tsar Bomba, the Soviet
“mother of all bombs”, had a yield of
about 50 megatons.
Needless to say, SCP-2966 going critical and
exploding would very likely be an XK-Class
Doomsday event.
Aside from blowing up half of Canada, it would
cause wildfires, tsunamis, and easily blanket
the sky in ash and soot, choking out plant
life.
And that’s all aside from the massive human
casualties.
The Foundation has long since realized that
even though Outpost 117 is out of the way,
SCP-2966 going off would be much, much more
than even they could handle.
Thus, the containment procedures currently
in place: keep SCP-2966 right in the sweet
spot so that it doesn’t need to absorb energy
from people, but make sure it doesn’t get
enough energy that it decides today is a great
day to extinguish human life as we know it.
When SCP-2966 was being used by the D-class,
they noticed something a little odd.
The D-class, from the toilet on their radios,
reported that the room temperature of the
containment chamber seemed to drop a little.
The researchers aren’t quite sure of what
this means yet, but the D-class also reported
that the paper removed from SCP-2966 is exceptionally
comfortable, strong, and effective as toilet
paper.
A handful of the researchers submitted a proposal:
to remove sheets of toilet paper from SCP-2966
and reroll them to send to other Foundation
facilities.
But due to the risk and possibility of accidentally
creating another SCP-2966, the Council denied
it out of hand.
So now we’ve got a much better understanding
of what the heck SCP-2966 is, and how a little
roll of toilet paper could pose such a massive,
overwhelming threat to not just the Foundation,
but all human life.
And why the containment procedures are as
extensive and thought-out as they are.
The research teams at Outpost 117 are hard
at work performing additional research on
SCP-2966, but there are still big questions:
most importantly, how was this thing created?
Who created it?
And how did the Foundation get ahold of it
and learn what it could do without accidentally
detonating it?
Well, SCP-2966 was discovered after global
weather satellites noticed the temperature
dropping in a small part of the Canadian wilderness.
The Foundation, being tapped into the global
information network, also noticed, and realized
the temperature drop was anomalous.
Agents in the area confirmed that something
strange was going on, and Mobile Task Force
Theta-19, the Rocketeers, found a small research
facility named “Pine Range Research” out
in the backwoods.
But that wasn’t the strange part - the strange
part was how it was completely frozen over
for an entire square kilometer, despite it
being a warm summer day.
The MTF measured the temperature, then rechecked
it three more times to ensure they hadn’t
gone insane - the temperature was -108 degrees
celsius.
For comparison, the coldest temperature ever
recorded on earth was -90 degrees Celsius.
The research team are now able to say that
the only reason everything wasn’t at absolute
zero was because the breach had happened hours
ago, and the sun had time to warm everything
up a little.
The Mobile Task Force breached into the building,
and found a scene of devastation.
All the individuals in the building had been
killed from hypothermia and exposure.
As they went further in, they encountered
a lecture hall, with one researcher giving
a lecture to others holding SCP-2966.
Because SCP-2966 had completely frozen everything,
all the electronics in the building were corrupted,
and the Foundation couldn’t get any useful
data.
But the MTF did discover a handwritten journal
by the researcher in one of the offices, and
were able to recover small sections of text
after thawing it.
The journal was just a small diary of research
notes and daily happenings from the researcher.
It detailed how the Pine Range Research Company
had achieved a huge breakthrough in toilet
paper technology.
Their new, highly effective toilet paper formula
was somehow infinite - the company had been
experimenting with anomalies!
They planned to monetize the product and even
expand into other paper products.
But a few weeks later, the researcher detailed
how the project had hit what he called ‘a
minor setback’.
They weren’t able to produce cellulose fibers
that make up the paper fast enough to make
the roll truly infinite.
It would eventually run out before restocking
itself.
But he had a solution in mind, though it was
rare and expensive.
Using a halved isotope of the element hafnium
known as ‘quarternium’, though the Foundation
hasn’t been able to find any other evidence
of such an element.
The researcher admitted that he was a botanist,
not a physicist or chemist, but that he was
perfectly capable of understanding the research
papers written by his colleagues on the matter.
He claimed that in this day and age, anyone
with a doctorate should be able to understand
others’ work, if they wrote it clearly enough.
He was dead-set on figuring out a way to make
his project work.
And work it did.
The very next entry detailed how the metallic
housing of the toilet paper was complete.
The initial roll of toilet paper had been
added in and soon the quarternium alloy would
be complete, for insertion into something
called the ‘hyperbaric containment field’.
They were still running into issues here and
there, particularly on the matter of the radiation
that it was constantly emitting.
But the researcher was confident that they
wouldn’t hamper the rest of the design.
Unfortunately, from the frost damage, the
remainder of that entry was rendered illegible.
Another entry the Foundation was able to recover
from the journal was dated to the day before
they encountered the temperature drop in the
Canadian interior.
The researcher wrote about how the energy
required for the production of radiation and
from it, the toilet paper, was higher than
he expected it to be from his calculations.
But he wasn’t worried, and planned to rework
the calculations slightly differently.
He didn’t have time to walk it back for
more extensive testing and modeling, since
the first test of the prototype was tomorrow.
From what the entry read, he was excited that
the world would never again need toilet paper.
The rest of that page was filled with equations,
only some of which the Foundation were able
to decipher.
But the Foundation mathematicians discovered
what went wrong when they solved the equations
by themselves: the researcher had made a very
simple error early on when calculating e=mc
squared, which led to his entire work being
thrown off and coming to a conclusion that
the energy output wouldn’t be nearly as
high.
Of course, the researcher was tragically,
and fatally, incorrect.
His desire to save the world from toilet paper
shortages might have been prescient, given
current events, but his lack of care and patience
led to the deaths of him and all of his coworkers,
and the creation of SCP-2966.
The Foundation moved in and suppressed the
event with a cover story of a burst liquid
nitrogen tank, and amnestics were disseminated
to any local witnesses.
Since the Foundation couldn’t safely move
SCP-2966, they chose to convert Pine Range
Research to Outpost 117, and contain it where
it was.
But SCP-2966’s story isn’t quite done
yet.
Remember how I mentioned that Foundation personnel
aren’t allowed to try reducing SCP-2966’s
weight since the incident?
Well, a few months after SCP-2966 was contained,
an experiment was performed to see if SCP-2966’s
mass could be reduced if they pumped it full
of energy while rapidly removing sheets.
But SCP-2966 immediately went critical, and
exploded, albeit with a much lower yield than
if it had been fully energized.
Outpost 117 was completely destroyed and all
the staff were killed, though no civilians
were harmed.
But in the smoking crater, SCP-2966 was recovered
unharmed and significantly lighter.
Though the Foundation has rebuilt Outpost
117 and recontained SCP-2966, they’ve learned
that simply letting it explode by itself is
not a solution.
This toilet paper just won’t quit.
Now go check out “SCP-1984 - Dead Hand”
and “SCP-186 - To End All Wars” for more
explosive anomalies from SCP Explained!